i've never watched jeopardy before
really yeah actually
why did that have to answer like what is
like grant i don't know
because because what the instead of the
question they give you
like an answer and then you the answer
is the questions
i've only seen like out of context
jeopardy tweet uh jeopardy clips and
i've just always tried to figure out
why are they answering in questions i
feel like it's pretty easy to figure out
what's going on well now that you've
explained it now of course it's going to
be easy now they'll explain they had to
tell me what was going on i was like i'm
guessing based on you know
what's going on i can't i can't recall
the moment in my life where i was like i
need to know how this game works
all right good job i can't even remember
the last time i watched a game show it's
just
yeah yeah did you watch any game shows
growing up
yeah i actually watched quite a lot we
have quite good ones in the uk yeah like
how to be a millionaire that was
classic classic games you guys have like
a deal or no deal
that was a what country originally made
that america america but we had like an
australian version
yeah the british one went for a long
time yeah we had like who's the host
no edmunds yeah have you seen the
american deal or no deal no
it's like it's like deal or no deal but
like it's way more
hollywoodized is it literally just like
the kitchen nightmares deal where like
kitchen nightmares usa is like
boom you won't believe what happened and
then the uk one is like gordon's like
all right come on you gotta you're
acting good
it's it's just it's way bigger they got
like it you know instead of just [ __ ]
noel edmonds
like opening the briefcase or some or
something it's they've got like the
proper
you know um boxing ring chicks that like
you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah like the models that
open up the briefcase you compared to
like the british version and it's just
it's just night and day wait does the
british version not have because i i
think we have
the boxes we have the boxes oh because
in australia that we
took the american thing we lined up like
30 chicks can we explain what deal and
no deal is
you're someone who might not okay it's
basically like a contestant comes on
um oh wait opens a bunch of briefcases
they have to get down to how do you wait
so they get down to two
boxes don't they yeah okay so uh if i
remember correctly you have
i can't remember like 15 boxes or 15
briefcases
it's like 25. is that 25. yeah and i
believe
you have to like you have to choose
random briefcases
and they get knocked out and then like
every briefcase has
a different amount of money in it and
when you choose that briefcase that
amount of money is knocked out of the
prize pool
and nobody isn't it they they pick a
briefcase first and then
and they hang on to it but they don't
know what it is oh yeah yeah yeah and
then
there's basically what they do is is the
reason why they don't just immediately
skip to the final one which you pick is
because along the way based on what
you've knocked out or got in so say
you've knocked out all the lower prize
pools
like the 1000 pounds the 2000 they'll
offer you
deals yeah yeah so the whole point of
the show is that you kind of want to
knock out all the small ones at first so
that they
might offer you a really generous deal
which yeah because your box might be
like the one that's left
yeah yeah it's it was always a really
fun game show and i really liked it but
in the uk i don't know if this is the
same in australia but like
all ages watched like the quiz shows
like the daily show yes yeah yeah
i just couldn't see like my my grandma
watching
like bikini models [ __ ] open up box
my grandma was [ __ ] obsessed with
deal or no deal oh
my my great grandma too as well yeah she
was i don't know what it is watched it
every day
yeah wait but did you guys not have like
the
the the supermodels like without cases
no all game shows are like
unapologetically like just like chill
people
just doing like like for normally for
small amounts of money
but then on the opposite of the side of
the spectrum you guys have shows like
naked attraction yeah i mean i i don't
know i mean that's still a small scale i
i would say
because even like pointless which has
been like uh if you don't know what
pointless is it's kind of hard
to just [ __ ] google it i don't know i
don't explain every single game [ __ ]
that we talked about
um pointless their prize pools are only
ever like 1 000 pounds
right yeah which is really yeah she's
like to go on
to go on you know national tv it's like
for like what like one thousand five
hundred dollars i know one thousand
three hundred dollars
not really a lot if that's if you win
yeah yeah nothing if you don't at least
no deal had like i think the prize pool
the top prize was like a million dollars
or something
250 i know it pounds for oh really okay
it was like a million i think that's not
too far off but i mean i
you never saw anyone winning the mill
the price pools in general on the uk
quiz shows are pretty small except for
like the big ones which are marked as
like the big ones
i think the biggest one we had was who
wants to be a millionaire yeah that was
the yeah
that was the whole i mean i think that
was the biggest one anywhere right
now then like they probably like the uk
version was probably like the most
expensive just like [ __ ] why
why is our currency so god damn strong
you know a million pounds a lot of times
yeah imagine a japanese who wants to be
a millionaire
we have that it's like did you just win
a million yen um
i think uh wait what is it again ashley
do you remember like
how much money is it for the japanese
who wants to be a millionaire i didn't
even know
japan oh yeah never mind i'm pretty sure
it's a million
no it's 10 million yeah that would make
sense because
we spoke about it before i remember like
takeshi's castle yeah uh the japanese
version i think it was three million yen
was the prize
yeah i thought for a game show that
[ __ ] hard thirty thousand dollars
doesn't seem like a fair reward for a
show that only like five people ever won
but in most japanese
quiz shows yeah well it is about the
money but when it is about the money the
max you get is like 10k
and usually and usually that's split
because like usually it's like a team
based
oh no i think so it's like you guys win
10k split between the five of you so
it's small and then
after taxes so you probably get about a
grand like what's your like favorite
australian or like american
game show that you've ever seen oh god
i i'd probably say deal or no deal was
probably mine
i really liked family fortunes i don't
know i don't know what the american one
is but
family feud i've seen like the american
like clips of the american one and that
seems
as fun if not even better than the
british version because like on the
american one i feel like they have like
more celebrities to choose from
exactly right exactly we only have like
a few very
giants yeah we had like les dennis which
i don't even remember what he was famous
for in the first place
because because like in america you have
like celebrities which normally are
known like the world over
yeah yeah that's just how it is but in
the uk you have like two tiers of
celebrities which are like
legit like massive celebrities known all
around the world like you know like
normally musical artists or like really
big actors and then the locals then you
have like the locally known ones which
are normally like just like um the
comedians are pretty good
like outside of that you have like
someone who's like he said the
a racist word on tv and made a career
out of it one time well
yes i mean okay it's the same in
australia yeah i mean
in australia it's like you're either an
internationally known like star who's
hosting the show
or you're an australian comedian that
failed to like market themselves outside
of australia yeah yeah so he's just like
we'll give you a spot
you speak an australian